NASIR KHAN: Hello everyone, and
welcome to another episode
of Google Wallet Developers
Live.
My name is Nasir Khan.
I'm a developer advocate
with Google Wallet.
Today's topic, we have a
very exciting lineup.
We're going to talk about
recently announced Google
Wallet InstantBuy
API for Android.
And we have one of our
partners, Expedia.
Dan Lew is here from Expedia.
Welcome, Dan.
DAN LEW: Hello.
NASIR KHAN: And we also have
Nagesh, who is a developer
programs engineer
here at Google.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Hey.
NASIR KHAN: So one of the main
issues with Google Commerce
really is the form factor.
So wherever you're trying to
book anything or trying to buy
anything on a mobile device,
you run into an issue where
you have a small device, you
have to enter your name and
address, your credit card
details, your billing address
and so forth.
And no matter what you're
buying, physical supplies,
office supplies, t-shirts, even
booking at Expedia, you
have to go through
that process.
So the recently announced
Android API, InstantBuy API,
is trying to solve that problem
in a very elegant way,
reducing the friction the user
has and just gets them to
really what they want--
to purchase something.
So first of all, Dan, welcome
come to Google again.
And can you tell us a little
bit about Expedia, what is
happening there, what's new,
what's latest, and
what you guys do?
DAN LEW: Oh yeah.
I mean, Expedia is a well-known
international
travel company.
And we help anyone book hotels
and flights and car rentals
and activities and
even cruises.
NAGESH SUSARLA: So
Dan, you have a
fantastic app here on Android.
And what can you accomplish
with it?
DAN LEW: So what our application
handles at the
moment are hotel and flight
searches as well as bookings.
So you can go through the entire
process from start to
finish in terms of getting a
hotel stay for the night or a
flight if you need
to get away.
And we also just recently
released a new version of the
application that includes
itineraries.
So anything that you book
through Expedia, either
through the app or on the
website, you can look up on
your device afterwards.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Nice.
So the launch screen of the app
looks pretty fascinating.
It has the hotels and the
flights scrolling
at different speeds.
How do go about implementing
it?
I mean, I'm very curious.
DAN LEW: Oh yeah, this was
super fun to work on.
And it's essentially two list
views side by side.
And there's a handler that
automatically scrolls them up.
But what's really unique is that
they're linked to each
other, at a different rate of
scrolling on each of them.
And whenever you click and start
scrolling one, it will
take over touch events for both
of them and pass touch
events from one to the next, so
that they're both linked in
their scrolling.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Nice.
NASIR KHAN: Very nice.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Very nice.
NASIR KHAN: So Dan, you've also
integrated Google Wallet
with this app.
DAN LEW: Mm-hmm.
NASIR KHAN: So what was
the motivation?
Why did you guys decide to do
that in the first place, and
how did you go about it?
DAN LEW: Well, it's very related
to what you were
talking about earlier,
which is that--
I mean, we allow you
to book hotels and
flights through the app.
And these things require a lot
of information from users.
And so it becomes a very painful
process right near the
end, where you've decided on
the hotel that you want to
book for tonight, but now you
have to enter your name and
your billing address and your
credit card information.
And we want to really reduce the
amount of friction that it
has for users.
And in addition, Google Wallet
comes with every
Android phone now.
So whenever you--
any new users to the application
will already have
all this information
they can pre-fill.
NASIR KHAN: And could you
show us that experience?
DAN LEW: Yeah.
So let's just select a random
hotel on the left.
And so I'm at this point where
I'm checking out the hotel and
seeing if it's where
I want to stay.
And I've read through the
details, and I decide this is
the one for me.
So I Select it.
And at this point now is the
normal checkout screen, except
for now we have the Buy
with Google button.
And so when I click on that,
it'll bring up a page with my
different credit card that I
have saved in Google Wallet.
So I can either pick one that
exists now or add a new one.
And I click Continue.
And it will pre-fill all of that
data into the booking.
And now all I need to do
is slide to purchase.
And the hotel booking
will be complete.
NAGESH SUSARLA: That's
very awesome.
So when customers purchase for
the very first time, a chooser
is shown with the check box
where they can indicate if
they want to use Google
Wallet for future
purchases with Expedia.
Now if that is selected, the
next time they go through the
purchase flow, the chooser
is not shown.
Can you show us that flow?
DAN LEW: Sure.
So we finished booking
our first hotel stay.
And so now we can look at a new
search and see if there's
another hotel we want
to stay at.
And by the way, this is our
little hanging tag animation
that we like to show.
We like to show animations so
that people don't get too
bored while they're looking
while we're gathering data.
So let's stay at the
Courtyard tonight.
I guess we'll book a whole
bunch of hotels.
The free cancellation's good,
because we're booking all
these things.
So again, I've now
gotten through.
I've selected the room.
I'm checking out the details.
I scroll to the page from
before, and all that data is
already entered.
NASIR KHAN: And that's because
you'd selected a check box in
the first time around.
DAN LEW: Mm-hmm.
NASIR KHAN: Very nice.
DAN LEW: And so all I have to
do this time is slide to
purchase, and we're booking
that hotel as well.
NASIR KHAN: Fantastic.
That was really smooth.
So just by a couple of clicks,
next time around, you're just
able to book a hotel without
any entry really.
DAN LEW: Yup.
Although if you wanted to, it's
a pretty open platform.
And so if the user wanted to
book a hotel on behalf of
someone else, they could
change the name of the
traveler on it.
So while it does pre-fill that
information, it also gives you
the ability to customize what
information's sent as well.
NASIR KHAN: Great, great.
Just to keep things in
perspective, so if I could
take you back in time to the
time when Google Wallet wasn't
there or maybe to a flow where
you don't use Google Wallet,
how does that experience
look like?
DAN LEW: Sure.
So we can look at the flights
portion of the app right now,
which we do not have Google
Wallet enabled for.
And so again, this
is kind of our
animation that we're showing.
And so I'm going to pick
just any given flight.
And with flights, it's a lot
worse than hotels, because the
amount of data you need to
book a flight is actually
greater than you need
for a hotel.
And so I'm going to have to
enter in my name, I'm going to
have to enter in my phone
number, and I'm just going to
make all this data up and go
as quickly as possible.
And even then, like if you're
actually having to fill this
out, it takes a while.
I have to enter in--
I have to know the gender
for TSA purposes.
And that's just the easy part.
Now I've got to do the payment
information, and I have to
enter in my address and
where I live and a
state and a ZIP code.
And now I have to enter a
credit card number and
expiration date and the name
that's on the credit card that
I'm booking with, in case it
happens to be different from
the person who's actually
travelling on this flight.
And now, only at this point can
I then slide for booking.
And so that's like 10, 15
different fields I had to
enter data for.
So clicking a button
is way easier.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Yeah, that looks
pretty painful to have
to type in your credit card,
your billing address, and all
the other details.
And that's really what Google
Wallet is here to solve.
And talking about integrations,
how easy or
difficult was the integration?
How has the experience been
so far, the Google Wallet
integration?
DAN LEW: I mean, payment
processing is an inherently
complicated issue.
And so the initial happy path
from start to finish took just
about a day or two to finish.
But then there's handling all
these situations where like
maybe their credit card's out of
date, or you need to handle
that daily transaction within
or something like that.
And so overall, it's taken about
two or three weeks to
fully integrate the
application with Google Wallet.
But it's completely worth it,
because it makes the checkout
flow so much easier.
NASIR KHAN: Yeah, two to three
weeks is pretty awesome given
that you're doing
all that stuff.
If you were to do it--
I mean, you've pretty much
done the app yourself--
been first on yourself--
so the payment processing part
must have taken quite longer
than two, three weeks at the
integration [INAUDIBLE].
DAN LEW: Oh yes, certainly.
I mean every time we have to
deal with payment, it becomes
a complex issue.
NASIR KHAN: So in terms of the
benefits, of course, you
already talked about it.
Is there anything else that
you want to share with our
developers in terms of
any tips and tricks
that you came across?
Anything that you think made it
easy for you to integrate
with Google Wallet?
Or in Android apps in
general, anything
that you want to share?
DAN LEW: Oh, sure.
I can talk about some Google
Wallet tricks that we used.
One is that there's a lot of
life cycle events that you
need to handle on a regular
basis throughout your
application for Google Wallet.
And so I found it very handy
to create a Wallet fragment
that kind of handled many
of the common cases.
For example, like initializing
the connection and
disconnection from Google
Wallet itself.
And so even though we had six
or seven different places in
the app using Google Wallet,
I could keep
reusing this common logic.
And the other thing is that
it's kind of a two-step
process, where the first step
you make an estimate of how
much you think it's going
to cost for the user.
And that's when you get a lot
of the initial data back.
You can't actually
book anything
with it at that point.
But you can actually check all
that information as soon as
you have a pretty
good estimate.
And so if you send all that
data earlier, rather than
later, when the user clicks the
Buy with Google button, we
can instantly fill out
all that information.
If you wait until you get to
that point, then you might
have to be waiting spinning
a little bit while you
give that data back.
NASIR KHAN: And then have a
magical user experience.
DAN LEW: Yeah.
NASIR KHAN: Get instant
[INAUDIBLE].
DAN LEW: So if you set it up--
so if the users add all the
stuff to their cart and they
click Check Out, maybe you
don't know the taxes
and shipping
information at that point.
But if you start doing that
processing right then, you can
already have the result back
once they're ready to book.
NASIR KHAN: Great.
NAGESH SUSARLA: Awesome,
that sounds awesome.
Well, thank you so much, Dan,
for taking the time to share
your thoughts on Google
Wallet integration.
And it looks fantastic.
And folks, if you're booking
your next travel, be sure to
check out the Expedia app and
Buy with Google Wallet.
Thank you.
NASIR KHAN: Thank you.
Bye.
DAN LEW: Thanks.